Oh
[Music]
all right now the term psychedelic is
usually associated mind-expanding
chemicals consciousness expanding drugs
that grow on the earth but the root of
the word psychedelic actually means to
make manifest the mind now you can see
why psychedelic substances you know
bring our visions into bead we call it
active hallucination so it is this not
in many ways the same thing as our
imagination and is technology not in
many ways a manifestation of the human
mind embodied imagination the
actualization the rendering of our
hallucinations into existence you know
the creature that ate the mushrooms and
then started doing art on the caves is
the same species that hallucinate it
starships into existence technology is
literally psychedelic it literally is
outsourced cognition and how we extends
the boundaries of the human mind the
goal
mind expansion the counterculture 1960s
ethos of expand your horizons transcend
your reality
that cognitive leap is no different than
the manifestation of our information
technology Google is the first
psychedelically informed superpower it's
visions of interconnectivity and inter
conductivity repository of all of human
knowledge becomes almost like like a guy
I like a collective consciousness so
again the whole notion is that we should
really come to understand that the whole
psychedelic revolution from the 60s
ended up being literalized by the
information technologies that have
transformed our world over the last
thirty years
you
[Music]